[Applause]
it was many ages before the earth was
shaped that the mist world was made
admit most within it lies the well that
is called his gale mere from which
sprung the rivers yet first was the
world in the southern region which was
named misspell it is light and hot that
region is glowing and burning and
impossible to such as our Outlanders and
of not their holdings there he who sits
there the land's end to defend the land
is called sutiya he brandishes a flaming
sword and at the end of the world he
shall go forth and hairy and overcome
all the gods and burn all the world with
fire
[Music]
then said Ganga Larry what tidings are
to be told concerning Ragnarok
ha answered great tidings are to be told
of it and much the first is this that
there shall come the winter which is
called the awful winter in that time
snow shall drive from all quarters
Frost's shall be great then and winds
sharp there shall be no virtue in the
Sun those winters shall proceed three in
succession and no summer in between but
first shall come three other winters
such that over all the world there shall
be mighty battles and that time brothers
shall see each other for breeds sake and
none shall spare father or son in
manslaughter and in incest so it says in
Voluspa brothers shall strive and
slaughter each other own sister's
children shall sin together
ill days among men many a whoredom an
axe age a sword age shields shall be
cloven a wind age a wolf age air the
world taught us
then shall happen what seemed great
tidings the wolf shall swallow the Sun
and this shall seem to men a great harm
then the other wolf shall seize the moon
and he also shall work great ruin the
stars shall vanish from the heavens then
shall come to pass these tidings also
all the earth shall tremble so the trees
shall be torn up from the earth and the
crags fall to ruin
and all fetters and bones shall be
broken and rent then shall Fenris will
forget loose then the sea shall gush
forth upon the land because the Midgard
serpent stirs in giant wrath and
advances on the land then that too shall
happen that knack far shall be loosened
the ship which is so named it is made of
dead men's nails
wherefore a warning is desirable that if
a man die with unshorn and nails that
man adds much material to the ship
naglfar which gods and men were fain to
have finished late yet in the sea flood
not far shall float Fenris wolf shall
advance with gaping mouth and his lower
jaw shall be against the earth but the
upper against heaven he would gate yet
more if there were room for it fires
blazed from his eyes and nostrils the
Midgard serpent shall blow venom so that
he shall sprinkle all the air and water
and he is very terrible and shall be on
one side of the wolf in this din shall
the heavens be cloven and the sons of
Muspel ride thence sir th all right
first and both before him and after him
burning fire his sword is exceeding and
good from it radiance shines brighter
than from the Sun when they ride over
Bifrost than the bridge shall break as
has been told before the sons of
misspell shall go forth to that field
which is called Vigrid thither shall
come Fenris wolf all
so and the Midgard serpent then Loki and
him Rhea shall come there also and with
him all the Ryan Giants all the
champions of Hell follow
Loki and the sons of Muspel shall have a
company by themselves and it shall be
very bright the field Vigrid is a
hundred leagues wide each way when these
tidings come to pass then shall him now
rise up and blow mightily in the Yala
horn and awaken all the gods and they
shall hold counsel together then Odin
shall ride to Minnie as well and take
counsel of minier for himself and his
host then the ash of young drasil shall
tremble and nothing then shall be
without fear in heaven or earth then
shall the Aesir put on their war weeds
and all the champions and advance to the
field odin rides first with the gold
helmet and a fair Bernie and his spear
which is called gum near he shall go
forth against Fenris wolf and Thor
stands on his other side and can be of
no avail to him because he shall have
his hands full to fight against the
Midgard serpent Freya shall contend with
suit ear and the hard encounter shall
there be between them before frere falls
it is to be his death that he lacks that
good sword of his which he gave to
scania then shall the dog gamma be
loosed which is bound before nippers
cave he is the greatest monster he shall
do battle with tear and each become the
others Slayer Thor shall put to death
the Midgard serpent and shall stride
away nine paces from that spot there
Shafi fool dead to the earth because of
the venom which the snake has blown at
him the wolf shall swallow Odin that
shall be his ending but straight
thereafter shall Veda stride forth and
set one foot upon the lower jaw of the
wolf on that foot he has the shoe
materials for which have been gathering
throughout all time they are the scraps
of leather which men cut out of their
shoes at toe or heel therefore he who
desires in his heart to come to the ACS
help should cast those straps away with
one hand he shall seize the Wolves upper
jaw and tear his gullet asunder and that
is the death as the wolf Loki shall have
battled with him doll and each shall be
the Slayer of the other then straight
away shall suit ear cast fire over the
earth and burn all the world
hi blows him da the horn is aloft Odin
communes with min ears head trembles
eClass hills towering ash the old tree
wails when the Aten is loosed what of
the Aesir what of the elf folk all
Jordan hi echoes the Aesir art council
the dwarves are groaning before their
stone doors wise in rock walls with he
yet or what he mere sales from the east
the sea of floods onward the monstrous
beast twists in mighty wrath the snake
beats the waves the eagle is screaming
the gold nabbed tears corpses narrow fee
is loosed from the east sails the keel
come now more spells folk over the sea
waves and Loki steer a--the there are
the warlocks all with the wolf with them
is the brother of be leister faring
sortir
fares from southward with switch eating
flame on his sword shimmers the Sun of
the war gods the rocks are falling and
fiends are reeling heroes tread hell way
heaven is cloven then to the goddess a
second grief cometh when Odin fares to
fight with the wolf and Bella's Slayer
the bright guard with [ __ ] air there
must fall frigg's beloved Odin's son
goeth to strife with the wolf with our
speeding to meet the slaughter Beast the
sword in his hand to the heart he
thrusts a--the of the fiends offspring
avenged his his father now go through
Odin's glorious Sun not in flight from
the serpent of fear unheeding all the
Earth's offspring must empty the hosts
when furious might've mid guards
defender the Sun shall be darkened earth
sinks in the sea glide from the heaven
the glittering stars smoke wreak rages
and reddening fire the high heat licks
against heaven itself
you